would you like to step inside the home
of a minimalist
well now you can you can take a video
tour of my family home
and ryan's home over at
theminimalists.com
resources
my kitchen counters are the one thing
that always get cluttered
and seeing that mess stresses me out i
love cooking
it's one of my great joys in life but
that means i have a lot of tools
appliances
fruits and veggies ferments and sprouts
on my counters
[Laughter]
i know minimizing would help oh man but
i'm not sure
what i'd get rid of now any tips for
keeping organized
well that's first problem so um
don't confuse organizing with
simplifying
in fact organizing often
complicates our life the word complic
complicate means complex which is
to interweave two or more things
together
and what does organizing do it puts all
these things interweaves all of these
these things that we're holding on to
into a nice bin or basket
or a little tray or whatever it is right
yeah now yeah well it's like the plant
situation i was talking about
in the uh minimal episode it's like uh
cause
here are things that obviously add value
to her life
um if she wants to sprout and ferment
and freeze or freeze dry whatever it is
uh uh
if you want to do those things it's
going to take up some space and
you have to decide whether or not you're
willing to give up that space in your
home
for those items just like with the
plants like we have
we have some plants at home um we i
think i feel like we have an appropriate
amount but now i've got these like
tomato plants and the serrano plants i'm
going to go ahead and like do all the
work
put into it but it's going to make my
balcony a little bit more cluttered
but because of the fruits the literal
fruits i'm going to get
from these plants i'm going to
go ahead and allow them to take up a
little bit of space so
that's that's the decision now if like
if it's bothering me constantly then
we'll get rid of the plants
yeah so i mean yeah i think there's a
middle ground too and let me let me
say what we do with our so our counters
are exceptionally clean anytime you come
over
i have i literally have four things on
our counter
we have a hot water kettle we have a
coffee grinder yeah
we have a scale that met that weighs
coffee and they're all right next to
each other
now all now so that there's something
here about all three of those things are
beautiful
they cost a little bit more than if you
buy the really cheap versions
but they're beautiful so they look good
on the counter yeah we also have a paper
towel holder right
now if i lived by myself
i would probably have none of those
things even on the counters i i would
store those
right and the drawers cabinets whatever
because out of sight out of mind i but
because i live with the family we've
decided these are the four
things that we have out on the counter
everything else we do the work of
storing it after the fact
right like the instapot you have yes
it's out while it's being used
exactly when it's not being used you put
it away right it's not on top of the
counter our blender
we have a blender it's not on top of the
counter yeah we have several other
appliances that you would
generally just store on top of the
counter so the rule that i hear you
making for yourself is
if there's not room in the cabinets for
it then there's not room on the counter
for it
yes yeah and then there's not room in my
house for it basically
and and so let me just point this out
my wife is a registered dietitian and a
nutritionist she cooks twice a day
right it's not like well we just eat out
at every meal no
no she she cooks all the time it's just
we're willing we
you have to be willing to do the work
it's it's more work to
bring out the insta pot out of the
cabinet and we don't i mean
you've seen our kitchen it's tiny yeah
we have a small kitchen
right but what we do is we put in the
work to
store the things appropriately bring
them out when we need them
is it a slight hassle yes but it's less
of a hassle
than if they were there bothering me
every moment of every day in my kitchen
this is a great point because
if you all lived in like a studio
apartment you probably have less stuff
so that's a question that i forget who
the name of this person asking it
but theresa she needs to ask herself
like okay how much room do you have
in your place that everything that you
just mentioned
is that appropriate for the size of your
kitchen yeah um
and then have more the things you're
gonna have on your counters if you're
sprouting and all this other stuff
get the things that are aesthetically
pleasing to you it doesn't have to be
aesthetically pleasing other people
but the things that you enjoy the most
so they bother you less
the fact that they're on your counters
yeah you have a
really beautiful uh water kettle and
like having that out
if it was really ugly you had this
bright orange and red mismatched
you'd be like oh god why don't i have
this on the counter but it's less
obtrusive because
in a way it's sort of like a work of art
right sure so so if you think about it
that way you can
have things that are that are photo
worthy
artworthy pieces of
useful things on your counters as well